you
all right we are ready to go this is a
3-2 blitz tournament one hour of blitz
chess three to time control b3 okay I
guess we'll start with d5
and just play it pretty simple get my
bishop out
no I'm not gonna be too quick to move
myseif on because a little bit fearful
of Bishop b5 so let's go here actually
I'd have to worry about a pin against my
knight when I look to control this
square
should I do that right now
now let's castle maybe my night does go
to c6 should I have taken some time out
to preserve my light square bishop I
don't know it seems I'm fine with this
trade also there's no longer as much
control over this square so maybe I
could look to expand sacrifices here ok
I think I want my C pawn contributing in
my knight belongs on c6 I'm almost
certain so let's do that and go from
here meanwhile I guess white is heading
for Knight f3 which may run into this in
this move and my knight I'll get in
there let's do this Knight f3 I'm going
to jump in here and follow up with this
move Oh
let's just sidestep this advance with
the fork I don't want to move this pawn
too quick because it gives up these
squares to the knight not even on the
clock I'm looking for this stuff I know
this is a closed file to closed file
type move but he has the potential to
exchange himself up so see file may very
well open up
all right I think I want to keep
pressure on the epon and also look for
this really you going for some sacrifice
here
I don't know well not much I could do if
they want to really do this move it
seems very very odd
let's take once and then get my knight
to be six put pressure here
I can't recapture
have some squares for my c69 interesting
position this night can't go too far
this tension something needs to happen
with it I don't know if I want to push
here and get a past pond because why
let's do this
double temporarily and I think this is a
good position for me now takes opens up
the C file opens up a square for my
bishop what is happening over here
you really lining up a sacrifice on this
square take once now let's go here may
be threatening this capture maybe even a
push and then here now what I most
certainly forced them to do what this is
hitting everything I think they have to
take my knight if I do this hmm it's an
interesting moment huh I'm gonna try
this got to take my knight otherwise I
get some material they may be able to
just give me some material in sacrifice
here they'd be playing down a rook they
have some sort of Perpetual though maybe
you know I could block with my rook on
f7 if that happens
a little concerning
I also an important question for me is
how do I take if Bishop takes Knight I'm
not sure hmm they're prepared to sack
and then 94 there is some compensation
for that so much so that I'm not going
to go straight in from 93 yeah
let's go here he definitely can't go
anywhere huh oh no oh no no no no no no
I just don't if there might be some
night here move now I had that covered
enough what am I talking about this
structure here kills the bishop when I
put pressure here and defend against
this pawn push no against this sacrifice
actually
this idea of the Queen killing my king
and the rook coming over on the h-file
to be very delicate kind of want to jump
in right now now
my night is gonna get kicked away soon I
guess here hmm
let's open up this wing look for a five
I might have to just be alright with
night here what are the alternatives
not good opposite color Bishop's this is
a very committal move so okay I'm gonna
be down upon but more than that actually
my night is a big dummy here on b6
rook d4 is maybe a way to bring my
pieces to life if he's ever captured it
has have this square open I'm glad that
I'm controlling this what are they
lining up with that move Knight here Wow
a very interesting move
I feel like I want to take that night
I'm going to prepare against a sacrifice
on this square or prepare against a
night move but at the same time I'm kind
of just sitting and waiting okay so this
was my plan to give the piece back
otherwise I'm staring at this kind of
stuff I don't think they should have
jumped in I think I was more
inconvenienced they sacrificing here I
think they have to do something against
my king soon otherwise feels like I'm
just better wow I think I'm winning
though if they're not gonna have some
sacrifice here I have to say for King
better structure I missed that move
let's do this first
oh if I took with the Queen there's rook
g3 8 seconds not enough let's take that
pawn prepared to run here there bishops
in a pin my knight is not playing I have
a check on g5 oh they just dropped their
queen hmm that's an unexpected end and
they had a lot of pressure I was
definitely the worst side there yeah if
they did not jump there knight in to f6
so soon because with my queen on d8
what's happening is my queen is stuck
there defending against a sac on f6 and
in the meantime how do I get my rook
working I don't my rook on f8 never gets
to play and I believe they can move
their queen and start pushing their H
pawn to make progress meanwhile what do
I do
I think that's a moment where they
should have not pulled the trigger on
Knight f6 so soon
let's go here I'm preparing e5 Knight f3
f4 ah that's a very quick strike at e5
I guess we have to give him up this
guy's berserk and me by the way let's
make sure I control a five I don't think
I'm gonna be able to control you five I
think I have to invite my deep on into
the mix here and I could get one more
developing move in I don't think there's
any great night discovery should my
queen be opposite the rook
um they're preparing e5 right now I
guess I have to take I help them develop
Oh 95 was the other move silly all right
let's go for this
I want my knight to be able to move
before it gets to a point where this
pawns does start rolling and then he
gets kicked away
I want my bishops eyes to open up I want
I want to have these to exchange so he's
finally contributing at the same time I
have given up efore they still push with
that I don't think that that's correct
I'm actually the better developed side
can I put that to use I think we must
start with this and yes we'll take here
and what are they doing in this move
rook has to go here okay this is this is
some progress actually because what I
could do is consider see form in fact I
should have played c4 in the last move
maybe what no I have Bishop takes d5 and
at the end of it my queen would be
pinning their Bishop this is important
oh also worth noting is that when you
berserk you lose your increment so this
is pretty serious to say the least
I did have some fear of in the end the
bishop coming here for me but they can't
pull that off because as mentioned the
bishop is pinned otherwise I'm in big
trouble and they resigned yeah I think I
well I'm almost certain I miss played
that they did well to undermine my
center quick and I don't think I was
able to reinforce a five like I should
have I needed a couple more moves in if
I was able to get in let's say each for
Knight h2 into I don't know g4 but I
can't really go to g4 so soon they had a
knight on f6 short story I wasn't in
time to secure my e4 actually me five
point and so they started to get upon
roller going I don't think they
responded well to my d4 move I think
just C takes D Knight takes D and then
in the end e5 would have been better
alright so we have an Enzo Indian I have
four points the leader has ten that's
Castle black and gold oh nine thank you
very much for the subscription all right
let's prepare to form a dark square pawn
chain
because I'm viewing this position
already where as if I've already given
up my dark square bishop who is
unprotected at the moment but at any
point I could take out one of these
pieces I would really like to first see
883 this might be a moment to even open
up the position since my opponent has
wasted quite some time I'm only two
moves away from completing development
one two three four white is it really
worthwhile to do this
now I'm just gonna develop like this I
wouldn't mind seeing Bishop takes Bishop
or exceed me for I should say because
then when I drop my Bishop back I could
look at this f5 advance and crack open
the F file and my rook will be brought
to life if efore I'm not sure Oh
actually on e4 I could take the knight
and then take here excuse me
and I think that that's what I would do
a for I take and then take here let's do
it
pawn takes Bishop is otherwise I'm
winning some material ok well they have
the two bishops so this is going to help
my next decision I just want to be
assured that one of these two guys is
exchanged
you know pretty much forces White's hand
well it assures me that the LightSquared
bishop s-- will be exchanged so now I'm
an ideal I'm in an ideal position to get
my up on rolling I have good control
over this c5 square so deficient
structure doubled see puns c5 as a whole
it's a hole in it's a hole for white
let's get it running with this guy
I have g3 if the night is ever kicked
with f3 to be serious weakness I think I
should crack open this position or right
away because I'm up on time on board and
I have the f5 square play for my rook I
could have also captured this pawn I
didn't and take note of that but this
should be fine
Fischer of d4 I guess
can you still in the middle end without
a good home really go Kings side Queen
side there's no good home this is their
best piece let's improve my night and
look to take out the best piece I have
enormous nights with very good
possibilities many holes to work with
squares in front of these isolated pawns
are all holes and this is giving up
another whole like g3 I have the e-file
as a check
I'd like this rook to come over to give
the check so I'm looking more at Queen
h4 stuff in fact I could have played
Queen h4 instead of the knight move and
that actually would have been better huh
yeah I should have played Queen h4 let's
do it now and prepare to get my last
piece involved he is the best piece but
at the same time I like my knight on f5
who has some good possibilities there
are multiple gaps let's get here the
King is I guess going to run and I think
I'll just jump in here no he's not
running well I could just get out of
this pin and now there's gonna be some
serious issue with the knight I'm also
threatening Queen takes c3 under 50
seconds for white there was some and
that's how useful moves played by white
bishop C 2 and H 3 and this cost them
could win the Queen let's just go
straight in for it and I can maybe even
get fancy and take here first yeah
actually this works Czech Queen blocks
check yeah this is probably even better
and leading to me
the queen with the night if she blocks I
take the rook the Queen Esther block
again in this position and then enters
the rook now yeah give a check another
check on g2
and rookie
- if the Queen blocks
and mate next with Queen takes Queen
regardless of where the king goes
all right they resigned we have 8 I have
8 points
42 players I believe he just finished so
I think we're gonna get paired up again
self-service let's see 40 minutes left
in this one back three he berserk his
own oh this guy just now up there with
14 let's see what we get
okay self-service again playing his
black again okay
another b3 um
I'll revisit this same line and I think
I'm going to opt for h6 and preserve my
light square bishop right now let me get
one we're moving you played Bishop e2
last time okay now we're gonna do this
you could have also gone for this one
move earlier so I'm going to do the same
thing focus on e5 probably Castle now
let's let's get here and I
just want to reinforce maybe here first
actually c6 night here if I take I get
forked now I'm okay I'm okay if they if
they jump in here because I'm going to
put immediate pressure on it and then if
they playoff for I have the e4 square to
work with so I'm I'm liking my position
here it's a very solid structure I think
getting the a pond working looking for
an a for break is sensible
they've just weakened b4 and this is a
hole
Queen b8 comes to mind just to rule out
95 altogether but also what comes to
mind is just posting up in the center
let's do that and now I'm prepared to
take this was one of the ideas and I
think I'm winning material now with this
capture maybe I should play here right
away actually Knight takes Knight Knight
takes Knight I don't have to take that
night right away what are they doing in
this move where I'm threatening to win
the exchange I guess they have to try
for this
oh no no no no no no they could return
the night here I might be quite
disruptive though looking for this stuff
or maybe even looking to take with this
they might have to return the rook to f1
yeah let's do this
I should have captured first in I
believe they would have to take here
first I don't think they would lose the
exchange but they'd have to be accurate
okay now there's an option for Knight c3
even he's got to be really disruptive
here no picking up the light square
bishop but do I need to even take him
right away
I'll scoop them up
I don't know it feels active I don't
know that I want to recapture with the
pawn I think my queen could be pretty
pretty good on b4 okay now they're gonna
force that I am on the rook in the mean
time and I think with now c5 I'm able to
play on the C file their knight is
pinned should I just go straight in for
this or first capture the bishop I have
to be very careful because I have some
dark square weaknesses that concern me
I'd really like to exchange my light
square bishop
and you don't want to end up with the
pawn on b5 should I just go straight in
for b6 yeah oh I don't know if I should
do that hmm I'm gonna take and I'm gonna
do something that looks really weird oh
I would have expected Queen takes I'm
looking for an e5 brake next I don't
think I'll well you know what I haven't
ruled out yet I'm under fifty seconds I
haven't ruled out v6 yet in fact I'll be
I'll be able to get this in though
because of the pressure my knight has on
this square and this rook is offside
let's come all the way back just to
sidestep ninety five with tempo in case
my Knight wants to go elsewhere on pawn
takes I'm taking with the Queen because
I have a backward pawn and I'll look to
eliminate him as soon as possible for
whites perfectly healthy d4 pawn takes
Queen takes e5 is the very next pawn
break I'm looking for so they didn't
take so what this means is I could take
and I have a majority in the center I
also have a Brooke that has play on the
B file I have good squares to work with
and I could probably post up in the
center or should I look for this move
now I don't have enough control over it
let's start with this
my queen is o night here threatens me
that could have been pretty scary
alright let's stop that idea 24 seconds
I gotta go faster
too much docking in this one I don't
like that my queen has to watch over
this pawn but it's just how it is for
the moment given time I'd really like to
kick this night away maybe just pile up
on the B file yeah
this Knight is no he can't move in fact
I'm already threatening e5 in fact II 5
and then d4 yeah let's do it
I get a tempo against the Queen I'm
going to take the knight one of them
let's do this first and then here
yeah let's take one night I don't
believe in attack against my king with
just one piece the Queen will be enough
okay let's hit the Queen
that wasn't best I should have stayed
doubled on the B file let's go here work
myself into a pin ah okay maybe now we
could take eight seconds how could I get
away with this move and then here I
don't like my technique here in fact I'm
in a pin that I just can't get out of
now is this a move it is didn't
calculate
that might be getting mated
six seconds
yikes this is how I have to defend
fortunately oh there's that move
Wow
sad man sad this was very very bad
technique no good man I'd really really
spoiled this one I think I'm in I have
no no shot don't even know what I'm
threatening with this last move I could
have even played here and won the piece
back I guess it's a bunch of checks now
fortunately the rook isn't playing for
the moment
hmm
petrol tonight is in a pen I should be
looking to attack the night
I don't know how to even make out what's
going on here are they stopping my pond
winning this oh they have that move can
I hold this to a draw let's pick up this
pawn
Wow oh I'm gonna try to hold on to this
one get behind the phone I guess
okay I guess their night is gonna have
to defend he's gonna be the block hater
I think it should be the rook who's the
block hater
hmm I don't think my opponent went about
it the right way because now I'm going
to be the one pressing for a win Wow
don't end up in a fork man they're
offering a draw I'm gonna try to win
this one Wow
okay maybe I could try to torture white
maybe with this distance between the
king and rook there's not going to be I
could have just taken the pawn and
should have be picking him up next least
I thought let's go here this game is not
a good one for the tournament because
probably will end as a draw but I think
it's still the correct thing to try and
win this one I don't want to lose fire
all right let's try to let's try to put
pressure on the clock maybe force them
into something force them into something
50 moves Oh less than 50 moves there's a
fork maybe better in the end
oh what a back at forth game I was
better winning and then they were
winning and then I had a slim chance of
maybe waiting I don't know what what
what to make of it okay once and fast
forget about it we got 10 18 is up top
18 13 10 10 10 and a few more tents all
right let's try it for less than 30
minutes Wow
where has the time gone who know I'm not
gonna take their let's play
four nights huh okay
go for this ready you know we're gonna
play in the center my opponent wasted
some time so I'm gonna look to take
advantage of that they have the bishops
but I have a lead time wise slight but
it's there to invite a new piece into
the action the Queen II would I really
do something like this that's probably
asking for trouble Bishop g5 rook a d1
and e5 that is a serious weakness
just scoot back a single square or yeah
right here's a good post stays out of
the bishops way keeps pressure here and
actually this is the weakness this is a
hole in blacks position I'm just gonna
target it boom boom and there's a big
trouble it's probably already losing for
black and you'd probably was necessary
to immediately kick my Knight rook a d1
this is collapsing and I think I want to
take with my bishop so that my night
ends up there hmm this can't be good
either
I have Knight c7 with check winning the
rook at least but this is maybe one
we're probably want to avoid ending up
in some puzzle maybe there's a mate
right around the corner here huh take
the rook or take the pawn yeah I'm gonna
go for this I'll have to take
the rook right away I should be looking
for me
push knight here that may end up doing
it actually these squares are under
control by my knight my pawn could
control this and I think we're gonna
have mate check and then 95 it's gonna
do it back determined that was a quick
one important to get a quick game in
there I do not have fire so in this next
game if I win I'll get two and then
we're back on streak I only have one
game in there with the four oh I see
Captain Obvious is in here and he got a
late start I didn't see him at the start
of the term and we would have been
paired up actually so a bit of a late
start but I see him in there let's try a
Sicilian against red yellow for
let's break up the pawn duel
secure my queen post nc7 and what next
okay we had this in the cyma what did I
play against okay yeah I played 2,300
player in the cyma land I took like this
so I'm gonna revisit this structure I'm
gonna immediately play e5 and yeah my
knight here f4 there's Knight F Knight
g4 with Bishop c5 they have to take some
care okay so they're not going for f4
let me rule out first Knight a5 stuff
although no bishop here is fine I could
meet Knight a four with now Knight d7 in
my bishop is not bothered by my knight
being on d7 so this is not an
inconvenience what also kept me from
playing b5 in this position was a lack
of development and the possibilities
that white can follow up with a for
looking to crack open the Queen side so
let's complete development here and this
may still be a maneuver I'm not only
doing this in reply tonight a4 okay oops
let's do what I said I was going to do
offset the knight
and I could look to next kick him and
then maybe even trade Darkstar bishops
which is desirable or even jump in with
my knight on c5
bishop here is no good because well it's
actually maybe possible I was thinking
there's a fork but my night is a bit
soft the end of that
all right let's kick him out stop him
from eyeing up my dark squares here and
this would actually threaten to win the
bishop who's lacking some squares here
at the same time it gives up d5
I like this move actually because I'm
going to win the bishop and I have
possibilities for Bishop c4 skewers or
maybe even Bishop b3 controlling d1 and
this may translate into me gaining full
control over the D file so we're
actually going to have this exact thing
happen well directly there's a skewer if
they take with the piece if they take
with the pawn that weakens b3 and then I
can look forward to pinpointing a
backward deep on I think that this is
best not to immediately give up any
material and I don't see any reason not
to go straight in for this punch against
the rook okay this Knight ready to move
don't think so let's get straight on
that D pawn who is weak I thought this
was an idea and you know white and
gunning for d4 as soon as possible
exchanging an unhealthy for a perfectly
healthy pawn in the lead top guy is at
22 hmm so let's see my
pretty natural stuff is just the
doubling on the D file I may have to be
on the lookout for skewers
how do they dislodge my bishop he has to
be a great great father actually this
idea Rick d2 and push needed more work
because I can get to see for picking up
some material so I think they have to go
with F farm no they're allowing this
skewer also they were even allowing just
me landing a fork here I should have
gone for that well in the end I'm gonna
get it let's take the rook first I'm
gonna be up a full rook now and now we
have this no good way out of it
Knight here is maybe the only try but
I'm pretty sure I could just take them
and then take here okay let's just do
this their best the best piece is their
Bishop soon so I'm just going to look to
neutralize that Bishop and then we're
doing good just get rid of their active
pieces I don't have any uh nothing deep
here no a sophisticated plan going on
you tries the good pieces of your
opponent and that's it okay and I like
making this move but
all right never just go here I could
have picked up the h2 pond
all right we're gonna go here and look
for c5
I'm not threatening to capture the
bishop but let's just go here anyway oh
my goodness I really fell for that they
they hit me with the skewer back
yeah still all right I'm playing up a
piece but I should have at least seen
that let's get a flight square h4 as
well like to invite the rook in here and
unpin my bishop at the same time look up
and over for some activity and there
down on time okay we have fire now
this next game is very important there's
only 18 minutes left in the games I got
six games and so does this top guy who
has a couple of berserks in there no
speed bumps at all and that's really the
difference 22 is he in the middle of a
game he is against self-service this is
their game and I already look a pro day
in 86 let's try let's try modern
let's see uh well that's an early five
let's challenge that pond that's in my
position right away continue still with
c5 um actually maybe f6 it's a very
early pawn moves not developing move so
I want to crack up in this position
we're going with c5 I may go on castled
here or no actually on this capture I
could bring my Queen now it's check
alright
this needs to be punished
I'm creating some gaps in my
am i doing this but I want to put an
enormous amount of pressure on e5 they
spent a lot of time trying to establish
that pawn on e5 I want to I want to hit
that pawn a real lot I want to force
white into capturing and giving up their
e5 point so moves like Knight f7 come to
mind knight c6 while it puts pressure on
e5 it may run into push push and then
Yanks that is a pretty cramping so as it
stands right now one two three let's add
a fourth attacker to e5
one two three four how many defenders
one two three they have to react here
gets in the way the bishop and at the
same time with threatened maybe this
move and this they take like this I'm
taking with the pawn or Bishop I don't
know I have some interesting options
regardless of what kind of captures they
make going at that so I'm lining upon am
I not
I think I want to take in this direction
first
um let's take here first I know I give
the night this square but I want to make
sure we could get maximum number of
exchanges in also there's new
possibilities for my queen now that
there isn't a pawn here so it's not just
a one-way street
Knight c3 I have Queen a5 with Czech
potentially I think I want to go in for
one more capture and I think it's best
to take with the deep on make sure my
queen is opened up here for when they
capture with the deep on I could have
their King go and castled so I've
successfully successfully broken up
their King position and I'm not so sure
I want to count trade Queens actually
because ok I didn't see that move I
think maybe I do better to keep the
Queen's on but we'll see as it stands
right now I'm up upon so I could also
look into making even exchanges could
kind of go either way keep Queens on or
or not less than 15 less left in this
tournament
it's really been flying by this was a
really fast to me at least this was a
really fast 45 minutes there another
think tank here what would I do is white
here and that move okay now no I can't
take and should take up with the Queen
check let's go for that
like Queen a5 the night house to return
let's kick him out and basically kicking
the knight out of my position with this
move he has to retreat
and I think taking here is good or
should I just develop yeah I'm gonna
develop
taking here and allowing the night into
this square means I have to deal with
possibilities 496 I don't want to
improve their night like that I'm
looking at night C 6 well I'm looking at
rook d8 next exerting more pressure on
d4 there was earlier attention given to
e5 but now the attention is pointed at
d4 and now I should really lean more
into initiating this capture or just pin
right away
I feel like pinning is best I'm ok with
this push I'm just gonna Castle if they
do that maybe I should have captured one
I don't know yeah this might be a tough
pawn to work around actually ok now I'm
definitely capturing the only question
is how I'm gonna take with the pawn not
just to under the pawns but I want to
throw a punch and I don't want to allow
this Knight my queen is hit let's react
and throw a punch back right in the
centres likely excellent ok I could just
counsel ya take
hon well if I took with the night it
allows their night to exchange and this
rook is he can see easily let's push him
he's passed maybe I take the rook maybe
but I don't like taking on the material
in this case I think it's better to
improve I don't want a weakened I mean
he's in my number one defender of these
weak squares when I recapture with the
Queen
although yeah I'll take with the Queen
I'm vulnerable to checks if I take with
the king let's go here rook is maybe
something I take now that the position
is simplified um I still don't want to
take actually now I'm taking the
material now oh they went for the
just up a full ruck they needed to play
queen takes bishop my rook is hit and
we're just looking to go here push
through with the pawn or maybe even give
mate bishop can control h2 they're down
a full rook and upon who you might want
to go a little bit faster oh they're
down on time now they resigned okay we
have 18 the top guy um let's see the top
Kyle DeLong all the while anyhow he
slipped out so I'm back for the top guy
does not have fire this is doable kind
of get some faster games in though
clearly not sure why I'm playing this
particular opening but try and make it
work let's get enough for before night
here
he's my rook we'll be happy once I'm
castled let's immediately question the
bishop if he backs up I could trap him
expecting this move this is what I had
prepared Knight here I could take Bishop
here I have g3 oh but that move I didn't
account for yonks Wow and that is a
sharp move extra
I have something fancy I think
Wow that is actually a move isn't it
trendy to take out the night which would
stop this Bishop h4 idea and this move
with the discovered check and I could
pick up the night next however the
complications are far from over because
Bishop here is hitting next and my king
is running but so too is the blacking I
think my king will find shelter on d1 so
let's get the piece back in comes Bishop
h4 I'm glad it's not the Queen think
this is best ok what an interesting
start out of what's normally a tame
opening and now we're going to have the
Queen's exchange and that's oh that's
quite all right with me Queen has to
actually no I'm just picking up the
night I thought when the Queen blocks
there defending the knight somehow brain
cramp could have even taken the rook no
I couldn't have and now I'm trying to
take the rook Bishop is pinned ok so I'm
off a piece early now and this one and
probably just Bishop here pile up on
that pinned piece follow up moves Knight
d5 and I may just win in exchange and be
up a full rook in the end probably
probably have to unpin somehow Queen
here challenge the piece that's pinning
actually this saves it
Queen d6 is the only save mm-hmm
I'm on this I have this move Knight
takes c7 so I'll be grabbing some more
material and that's actually running
into a quick mate okay whoo we are at 22
now tied for the lead and we have fire
hmm one more game in we have at the
sixth minute
six and a half mark and we're gonna get
paired up with self-service I imagine 56
players for this created tournament a
third time a third meeting he had oh he
has a five-point lead
oh what a tough pairing we have Captain
Obvious and I already not self-service
he would have I was before I just before
I got paired up I was wondering should I
be zerk and that would be really really
bad that's something that only Ferrari
does okay
yeah that's really tough doing without
berserk or excuse me doing without the
increment when you berserk so I want to
put immediate pressure on deform that's
my plan I want to I want to I want I
want to see white commit they're deep on
early I want some useful information as
fast as possible what are you going to
do with your deep on if they support it
with the night I could consider pinning
the knight on d5 I think I'm going to
drift towards the Kings side all right
let's do it
I could think about this there's two
gaps in White's position two wholes f3
e3 potentially a pawn I'm glad that
that's not hitting what's check I'm
gonna do this move first actually don't
know if it's fast but I'm gonna give it
a shot I want to see this move too
because it weakens b3 and then if the
Queen ever moves I have a for clamping
immediately down on this a B structure
so this is a very positional minded
advance here I also have ideas of this
so this is what I wanted and now I'm
going to drift in this direction looking
at night C 5 and then a 4 and they can't
really stop this idea so what this means
is that my queen side I have a very very
good lock down on the Queen side because
of this a5 idea they're stopping Knights
e5 but he won't be denied here I'm fine
with Bishop takes Knight I'll take with
the beep on and then look to play
against the backward beep on there's no
reason not to jump right into c5 here
I want my bishops eyes to open up I
could even consider Knight b3 however
not just yet they were threatening to
take out my knight and then take the a4
upon I'm a Dodge a bishop for a knight
capture and I think that's worthwhile
and there is no undermining my knight
because I could always recapture with my
bishop
let's get my f-pawn rolling at least I
think there's something better now I'm
going to go in for this f-4e for
let's see what they do we're gonna go
for that well I have my squares as well
they have this square I have this square
so I could look for this this is a dummy
piece he needs to do something else
let's keep the pressure on my opponent
clockwise what's the story with that
move you tried for a g4 break well flake
King eh eh for a reason I think my
nightstands really well right here wow
they're very active runs into this huh I
guess Queen h4 is the idea Wow don't
want to touch this pawn because they're
dark square Bishop is still around
scary interesting move man interesting
move all right
which rook
I honestly don't think it matters I
guess we got with this one
I guess hmm I want to make sure this
position doesn't get too locked right
here must be correct
ah my king belongs
sir towards the center
I should have done this when I had the
chance before my night moved I want a
light squared bishop fixture no I don't
actually I think he needs to watch over
these squares tough to assess this
position I mean after a week in my dark
squares I think let's start with this
Knight d4 it's clearly right around the
corner
there's only 59 seconds left in this
tournament so this one a little likely
not finish in time okay
King goes here I have 93 I don't know
let's just go here first reinforce this
guy I don't think g4 is on just yet
let's jump in I may even be okay with
giving up up up on hmm not just yet hmm
okay you know in order to make progress
I have to play on this side of the board
and looking for h6g five I guess
my king should be over here I'm going to
jump in here if the rook comes over
and why exactly oh man oh they did take
okay so they're gonna go after that pawn
they will get them
I have to take them now hmm all right
let's try 4g5 let's try to start some
trouble while I have a strongly placed
night
hmm close shop I don't think I net
myself anything by going here let's push
I think I can make some progress over
here the kingside may soon get shut down
it is let's make sure this is here
okay the attention is now going to turn
towards the Queen side and for as long
as I can maintain a grip over this
square they're basically playing without
the e pond they're up a pond but they're
really not playing with this pond I
really don't want to go elsewhere with
my bishop they're making a play here
which weakens the a pond that I'm going
to look to target their Bishop is also
loose should I take that fish up and
give up my strong Knight No
rook-a for double on the a file see they
have their up upon but they have some
weak stuff here night c5
let's try like this oh they have a night
move here huh hmm let's see if they take
they are taking I'm winning that pond
though no oh I'm getting some material
here no their king is super vulnerable
you know this should be winning yeah
this is a very easy base point for me to
cover now pawns are dropping left and
right
my rooks are pigs super pigs
don't have time though hmm
let's let's make some progress like this
I could have taken the Jeep on but this
will work though their King is a way out
of the action and I have a past seep on
now and their King can't go too far
could welcome trades keep pushing this
is a win and I could just do do like
this I don't need my pawn
just come over here to track these guys
down and they resigned hmm I don't know
if I should have made progress like that
it's probably holdable giving up the
bishop allowed ten points to enter the
action
I think necessary was night see too but
well c4 is dropping so the these
vulnerable points became super
accessible as soon as he was traded for
him but we were both in mutual time
pressure at that stage a lot of pawn
shifts and this last one really tough to
assess this is really a this last game
that was played is really one that you
have to probably have a lot of time for
to reevaluate with these different
structural changes and really assessing
who's the better side with each pond
capture or pawn move many many different
shifts in that one okay and that is a
wrap to and one our tournament that
really did for me again at least flew
right by top was self-service we had a
couple games in he was the one that I
drew against he had ten games in eight
games I had a games as well 31 24 22 top
three other two up there were 20 s 58
players and all oops
let's see page 2 3 4 5 & 6
okay to the 58 of you that took part in
this created tournament games oh all
right
you